Here's something very interesting. Uh, I'm
not actually sure what to make of it. Americans
in every age group see Donald Trump as a bigger
threat to world peace than other authoritarian
leaders, including Kim Jong goon, Vladimir
Putin, Shujing ping, and Nicolas Maduro. This
is from you. Gov. Check out the numbers. Generation
Z sees Donald Trump is the biggest threat.
Followed very closely. One point behind by
Kim Jong goon. Millennials see Trump as a
way bigger threat than anybody else to world
peace. 28% say Trump's the biggest threat.
Uh, Kim Jong loon at 17, and Putin at 16%.
Generation X agrees. Trump is the biggest
threat to world peace, but only by one point
over Kim John loon, 25 to 24. Then you've
got the baby boomers who see Trump as the
biggest threat just ahead of Kim Jong UN 27
to 25 I believe. Baby boomers start at 1945
and then you've got the silent generation
people born between 1925 and 45 who see Trump
as the bigger threat and they see interesting
geopolitical differences. They see Xi Jinping
as second 27 for Trump and 22 for the Chinese
leader. Absolutely fascinating numbers and
it would be interesting to see numbers in
other countries as well on on these same five
authoritarians. Now there's more important
implications here if Donald Trump is the biggest
impediment to world peace. This means by necessity,
by logic that under Trump, the United States
is an impediment to world peace. Now, that's
horrible for those of us who care about world
peace, having our president seen as the impediment
to peace is sickening and disturbing and disheartening,
but there's another issue here and you're
probably already getting a sense of where
I'm going to go.
It's not just under Trump that the United
States has played roles geopolitically that
have hindered world peace. You can argue that
the American role, I mean the I, I don't wanna
I don't wanna make it seem like I'm picking
the most important things, but I'm just mentioning
a few things. You can argue that the American
role in the nuclear arms race has been counterproductive
for world peace. You can point to American
intervention in Latin America over the last
many decades as running counter to world peace.
You can look at the United States choosing
to start numerous military engagements over
the last many decades as obviously running
counter to world peace. The, the truth is
that the U S has made many decisions antithetical
to world peace through foreign policy for
a long time. But in this particular point
in time, Americans correctly Donald Trump
as an impediment to world peace, the foreign
policy of the U S has been problematic for
a long time.
We can say it's cartoonishly more acute during
the presidency of Donald Trump. Now those
who believe that for example, Vladimir Putin
is doing the puppeteering of Trump. They might
see Putin as worse in that he's a proxy to
what Donald Trump is doing. And Trump is the
one sort of checking the boxes. Uh, Donald
Trump talks a lot of authoritarian boxes.
You've got a tyrannical megalomaniac bigot
with access to nuclear weapons, no sense of
common sense or decency while simultaneously
lacking basic knowledge about the world. And
even the most fundamental critical thinking
skills that is a dangerous recipe. And clearly
American's ranging from gen Z all the way
up to the silent generation agree, it seems
the disagreement that exists is how much more
of a threat to world peace is Donald Trump
than other authoritarians around the world.
And on that issue, people do actually seem
to, by divided by age and interestingly, older
Americans seeing the number two threat to
world peace as Xi Jinping, the Chinese leader.
Let me know what you think about this. Make
sure you're following me on Instagram at David.
Dot. Pacman. And while you're there, follow
the game
Pacman. Show on Instagram at David Pakman.
Show a ton of exclusive and behind the scenes
content regularly appearing the